we've got some interesting new
information tonight about Alexandria
Kazuya Cortez when she ran for office
last year she described herself as an
enemy of big money in politics watch
this really speaks to the corrupting
force of money in politics in general
and this problem is not going to go away
until we tighten the reins on the role
of money in politics I really hope that
we really pass introduced and pass very
strong legislation that's going to put
much stronger limits on how special
interests and how money can be moved
especially when they interface with
campaigns yeah she was like when money
moves and interfaces with campaigns of
course Kazuya Cortez is also a sworn
enemy of carbon but that didn't stop her
from taking hundreds of uber rides when
the subway was just a few feet away she
may feel the same way about money for
you but not for her anyway FEC complaint
accuses kasnia Cortez chief of staff of
diverting a million dollars in donations
into private accounts apparently to
obscure how that money was used if true
the complaint could result in prison
time Kazu Cortes was confronted about
this allegation today and here's what
she said
there's no renovation do you think
that's a sign of you taking a dark money
these people funded she wants you to
know speaking of people fighting Melissa
Francis who outs hosts outnumbered also
one of our all-time favorite people on
Fox Business joins us tonight for an
update on this story him listen he
Tucker's so so here's what this really
boils down to in my mind so it should be
noted that the group that brought the
complaint to the FEC is a right-leaning
organization we want to say that up
front but if you boil it down basically
what she and her chief of staff are
accused of doing is moving almost a
million dollars from a PAC fund that
they controlled over to an LLC a limited
liability corporation that they
controlled so were I her I would ask
this gentleman in the photo here who is
a multi-millionaire you know tech and
finance smart guy who's running her
campaign I would say hey why am i moving
this money these donations that were
made to me from this PAC over to this
other account that I control I control
them both why move it what difference
does it make yeah well what difference
could be look at the rules that govern
both and the rules that govern a PAC are
very clear and much more strict about
how much you can spend where it came
from what you have to disclose how you
list things when it's an LLC a limited
liability corporation the rules are very
different much lighter and she marked a
lot of stuff strategic consulting and
you can do that rather than itemizing
things now is this illegal I don't know
both sides are going to have their
arguments in court about this no doubt
and by the way the rules that govern
campaign finance are written by the very
people in power who were trying to hold
on to it so talk about the fox guarding
the henhouse
so the people who wrote these rules that
she's saying we're gonna rewrite the
rules more people who have come to power
and they're trying to hang on to it
so is this legal under the rules I don't
know we have people saying it's not both
sides will argue and we'll see but
what's interesting is you just have to
ask yourself why did you need to move it
from one thing you control totally to
another thing you control totally in
order to make the expenditure
it sounds like that dark money that
she's talking about but we will see when
they investigate well just I mean
quickly the fact that we don't know
anything about it the fact that it's not
itemized doesn't that by definition make
it dark money or at least opaque money
it doesn't make it bright money it
doesn't make it transparent money it
makes it obscured money at the very
least it is obscured there is not a
bright light shining on it but Tucker I
mean you made the point before thinking
about what socialism is like the very
definition is a government takeover the
means of production it's a power grab
yes that's what she's been all about is
a power grab I'm in charge I'm in the
boss I'm the boss we go to Washington we
decide we get the means of production we
get control and we tell you all what you
get it's all has the same theme if you
boil it down to its most basic sense so
she doesn't want other people using
planes but she'll use a plane going back
and forth between DC and York because
she's important it means she's she's the
ruling class she's powerful she's
important so she gets to do these things
but for you and me we're just you know
the serfs along the way so we we
shouldn't you know have a carbon
footprint we should know these other
things and I think you won the bus
Melissa Francis they have Wi-Fi
I love the bus way the Q train it's
right by my apartment I'll see you there
what's the Francis why thank you very
much